maybe that's the bill
I open the subcommittee meeting of
children and family law on retained Bill
HB
1590 training regarding abuse and
neglect prot
protection uh the purpose of this is not
a hearing we do not take testimony from
the public at this it is not a hearing
we've had the hearing on this and anyone
who has new information can get that to
the committee as a whole by emailing us
what we are here to do is to make an
informal recommendation to the committee
as a whole saying either yes we suggest
further
legislation or no we do not suggest
further legislation on this subject
that's all we do we don't amend the bill
that we are holding 1590 we don't amend
it we basically come on in have a seat
pick a
name I am suggesting that the committee
as a whole meets on Tuesday
October
22nd at
10:30 and the reason for that is there
some people from this committee who are
also excuse me I have
that was just a clarification of what
I've already said we do not amend the
bill before us we do not vote on 1590 we
simply use it as a jum jumping off point
to suggest either yes further
legislation would be a good idea and
which have at it November is Bill filing
time or we suggest no we don't recommend
further legislation which you can go and
file a bill on it anyway that's all we
do we make this as a subcommittee
recommendation that goes to the
committee as a whole I am suggesting
Tuesday October 22nd at 10:30 a.m. the
reason for that is we have a few members
of CFL that are also on the special F uh
family thing so that way uh we can be in
the same building
sequentially we will also have retained
Bill
1269 on the use of restraints in schools
and representative Petrino um chairs the
subcommittee on that once again this is
a work session for the subcommittee it
is not a public hearing therefore if you
have an update further information
something you would like us to know some
specifics you may e email the entire
children and family law committee and uh
with that since I believe representative
long you were the prime sponsor of the
original Bill were
you then I would say turn your mic on
and you may make your pitch one way or
the other
thank you Mr chairman um well I'll start
off by saying I believe that this
uh
um I would make the recommendation that
that this be uh would further legislated
should be considered um in that in that
there were uh questions that we heard in
testimony from the uh Hospital
Association that should be considered
and
also uh with there was an there was
another entity that wanted to be
involved in this uh which I thought was
um interesting uh they wanted to be one
of the
mandated um to take this training uh and
um what training identifying what the
training would be how often would people
need to be certified on this
training um and
other than that I believe
uh I believe that was those were the
only potential issues that would have in
this uh that is Bill as you recollect
the reason we um you and I I know both
voted to retain it was we thought that
there were some problems with the bill
that we didn't know at first but came up
and seemed to be beyond the power of
immediate Amendment
is is that correct that's correct yeah
okay yeah they're getting a consensus
yep
okay anyone else wish to on the
committee wish to speak one way or the
other to do we recommend further
legislation representative sidel you're
always backlighted I don't know whether
it's the building across the street or
your Halo probably it is her Halo thank
you very much
it's a little
crooked um I also think that we should
move forward with um continued leg
legislation on this bill I think it's
got great potential um I do agree that
that I think it should be a more broad
um group of people that not just so
limited on on who has to take this
mandatory training our First Responders
child Specialists and all of that I
think are sadly being left out of the
group um but I think would benefit from
that because they do tend to interact
with with um these children with these
families when these issues occur and
thank you Mr chairman for letting me
speak let me ask um representative long
since you will not be coming back to the
house do you have somebody who's uh
ready to file a bill in
November and the reason I ask is so that
questions we might raise could
be forwarded along yeah well I mean you
don't mention I'll be open but you know
in between door too I haven't been able
to come up with with somebody um okay
that I I haven't I haven't you know if I
make the Senate they they have a
longer time I don't know if this should
be brought here to the house or to the
Senate all I'm suggesting is if you are
aware that there is a House member who's
going to file a bill along on these
lines that person gets in contact with
us because we're making some suggestions
we can't amend the this bill but we
might speak into the next one if you
would yeah okay thank you anyone else hi
hi it's
okay all right forgiven now uh anything
to say about this we are uh not it's not
a public heing we are discussing amongst
ourselves the bill about uh mandated
education to senior medical providers uh
on training on abuse and neglect of
children and uh all we can do is make a
recommendation either yes let's has have
a bill or not have a bill that
recommendation goes to the full CFL
committee when we meet on October 20 2
at 10:30 so do you have any thoughts
about this
matter thank you Mr chairman I'm in
favor of recommending it for legislation
um I uh was really taken by the
testimony that I heard and um I would be
happy to work on a bill with whomever
might want to do
that great
representative deimon thank you Mr chair
I too would welcome the opportunity to
work with representative long current
representative
long uh on a bill that we can introduced
next year and hopefully when it gets
over to the Senate we can work together
to get it passed over there too sure
thank you representative ball
thank you chairman uh chairman Pearson
sorry um I too agree that we need to
work on this um a bit further and bring
it
forward now that leaves it to
me I have sent individual emails to
numbers of people the categories of
which are mentioned in the bill that is
to say
Physicians nurse practitioners
and physicians assistant I made sure
that I send it to Democrats as well as
Republicans and the answer I get back
from everyone is this already
mandatory uh medical ceu requirements as
to the number of hours a physician and I
would assume nurse practitioners and
Physicians assistants have to have each
year to mandate something and we don't
know what the new bill might say
uh does that mean it is now taking the
place of let's say two hours of
something else or does this mean it is
additional yet additional
study um that they will have to do so I
got some push back I also got
volunteered from several of them we have
studied this and in med school along the
way and uh everyone that said that said
and I have also reported one or more
people uh as here's a potential problem
similarly I'm hesitant to tell a
profession how to do its job we've often
said we shouldn't legislate the practice
of medicine we've often said that here
and wouldn't it be better if the
professional
association were lobbied so that any
additional
[Music]
CEUs were were from them and not from
us in addition there it begs the
question a recognized accredited
training program according to whom that
needs to be said and then finally under
listing uh senior medical personnel as
mandatory reporters everybody is a
mandatory reporter should we ask for
example gym coaches to be required ired
to take this training because they see
the kids running around in gym clothes
and oh my gosh that sure doesn't look
consistent with a kid being Rough and
Tumble that looks different uh how about
counselors how about others we are
looking at what sometimes people say the
first line of defense I might suggest to
you we know people who their kid hasn't
been to a doctor in een years so all the
training in the world cannot detect
something if the subject isn't present
but the gym coach might be so with all
of those
objections nevertheless to me they are
things to ponder in another bill so it
may sound to you like I would say no we
don't need further legislation I'm
suggesting we could use uh more fully
informed legisl ation this is not to say
anything against the uh Prime sponsor of
the bill 1590 it is to say we've learned
a lot in the process there's new
information new things that help us
detect better I'm just suggesting that
if a uh bill is um filed in November all
of these things that we've all said are
taken into account
uh anything else from the
committee seeing none we we don't vote
actually but I we can
nod um or raise a thumb if you are of
the opinion uh this is worthy of of
further consideration put your thumb up
or so that looks to me like six to and
uh if
not put you thumb up that looks like
none so it's the recommendation of this
group to the children and family law
committee as a whole which will meet on
Tuesday October 22nd at 10:30 it is the
unanimous suggestion that we go
forward and with that we
are
finished
e
e for